local mother-daughter duo will represent
las vegas on a new cbs show airing this
week it's called come dance with me and
it's a new family dance competition
series bianca holman introduces us to
this incredible pair
[Music]
[Applause]
the competition with some of america's
most talented young dancers and their
untrained parents and representing the
entertainment capital is this pair team
emeline and nicole henges at 14 years
old emilyn is the eldest of four and a
student at dance connection studio it's
a safe spot for me to like let all my
feelings go and just to have fun when
mom nicole first heard about the show
she had no clue she'd be the one to
leave her day job and take the stage
with her daughter who's been dancing
since she was a toddler and after doing
this show i have a new
found respect
for
what emeline and all the other dancers
out there do
because it is not easy in april of 2021
the pair quarantined in sydney australia
before filming in melbourne and boy did
they have some serious mother-daughter
time luckily enough the experience was
a pleasant one it was you know we we
made the most of it the teams learn
different dance routines each week in
hopes of earning top scores from the
judges all for a chance to win 100
thousand dollars the competition didn't
stop the kids and adults from connecting
we met so many new people i made so many
new friends it's
a bond that we will have for life long
rehearsals and keeping up with school
work the two-month competition was hard
work something that was great about
being on the show was that i got to
dance with my mom i got to learn so many
new things about her
um we got to
laugh together cry together
dance together
and um yeah i found out that she can
actually dance this was an experience of
a lifetime the show airs april 15th on
cbs bianca holman live local now